If you haven't tried
already to write
your own recursive
Fibonacci function,
I really encourage you to do
so, or at least to try to do so.
Give it a serious attempt
before you watch this video.
But if you have done that,
or if you're feeling lazy,
I guess you can
watch this video.
And so we're going to try to
write a recursive Fibonacci
function according to the specs
that I laid out when I first
set up the challenge to
write a Fibonacci function.
So I'll call this Fibonacci
again, and it'll take it.
It has a parameter here, n.
So someone will have to
pass an argument to it
to say which term do we want
of the Fibonacci sequence,
but here we're going
to do it recursively.
And what we're going to
see is that it's actually
very intuitive to write a
Fibonacci function recursively.
It's almost like magic.
And later we'll see,
though, it's not necessarily
the most efficient way to
write a Fibonacci function.
So what I'm going to do
is whenever you write
any recursive
program, you really
need to think about the
base cases really well.
And the base cases of the
Fibonacci sequence, there's
actually two base cases.
There's the 0-th term
and the first term,
and those are really
given by definition.
So let's just say if we want the
0-th term, if n is equal to 0,
well, that means you
want the 0-th term,
and the 0-th term is actually 0.
And you could say else
if n is equal to 1,
then you can return 1,
because the 0-th term is 0.
The first term in the
Fibonacci sequence is 1.
And now here is where a little
bit of the magic happens.
Otherwise return-- and
this is really cool
here-- the Fibonacci
of n minus 1.
So whatever the previous term
in the Fibonacci sequence
is plus Fibonacci of n minus 2.
And I think this should work.
And that's why it seems magical,
because all we're saying
is, hey, look, if you want
the 0-th term, it's 0.
If you want the
first term, it's 1--
Let me put two spaces here--
if you want the first term,
it is 1.
If you want any other term,
so else-- and this is else
if-- but else if neither
of these are true,
if it's neither 0 nor 1,
if it's some other number,
it's going to be--
and we're going
to assume that you're inputting
some non-negative integer
over here.
This would break down if you
did some non-negative integer
over the non-negative term.
But assuming you have
a non-negative integer,
then you say, look, if it's
not the 0-th or the first term,
then just take the Fibonacci
of whatever one term
less than it is, plus
two terms less than that.
And you could try it out.
For example, let's say
you took Fibonacci of 2.
Then n is not 0, so you won't
do this, and n is not 1,
so you wouldn't do this.
So you'll say return
Fibonacci of 2 minus 1.
So that's Fibonacci of 1,
plus Fibonacci of 2 minus 2,
plus Fibonacci of 0.
Well, we know Fibonacci
of 1 evaluates to 1,
and Fibonacci of 0 evaluates
to 0, so it'll be 1 plus 0,
or just 1.
And you could keep going.
Try Fibonacci of 3.
It'll work because we know
Fibonacci of 0, 1, or 2 works.
Because Fibonacci
of 3 will boil down
to Fibonacci of 2
plus Fibonacci of 1,
we know that Fibonacci of 2
is 1, and Fibonacci of 1 is 1.
So it'll be 1 plus 1 is 2,
so it'll just keep working.
And we could try it out.
Let's just save this.
Actually I didn't save the
file name, let me just call it
Recursive Fibonacci.
It's a dot py file.
And now let me actually
run the program.
And all this does is define
the function in my environment.
And then I'd actually
have to call the function.
So let me just run it.
And let me ask for
Fibonacci of 4.
It gave me the right answer.
Fibonacci of 10, 55.
Right answer.
I could try simple things.
Fibonacci of 0,
the 0-th term is 0.
So it all works out.
So that's why recursion
is kind of magical.
And if you wanted to
simplify this anymore,
you might recognize, hey, the
0-th term of the Fibonacci
sequence is 0; the first term
of the Fibonacci sequence is 1;
so really if you're
looking for the 0-th term
or the first term, it's really
the same thing as that number.
So you could actually, maybe,
simplify this a little bit.
If you assume that
someone is going
to input a non-negative
integer over here,
you could say something
like if n is equal to 0,
or n is equal to 1, return n.
Let's see if this works.
So this simplified our
code up a little bit.
So let's try to save this.
And now let's run it.
And now let's try,
Fibonacci of 10.
It still worked, because
really the 0-th term is 0,
and the first term is 1.
So it works there, or you
could even simplify it more.
If n is less than 2, that should
also work, because then if it's
0 or 1 you're going to return
n, and otherwise you're
going to do all
of this business.
So let's try that out.
So we ran it.
And let's try Fibonacci of 10.
Now, it seems like
the computer is
able to do this really
quickly, and all of that,
and all the rest of it.
But if you really want to
see all of the work that's
being done, all the
calls to Fibonacci,
what you can do is--
let's put a print in here.
So that every time
Fibonacci gets called,
it prints the text
Fibonacci colon.
And then I'm going to add
to that string of text
what the argument is.
So the argument in
this is going to be n,
and I want to make sure that
it is viewed as a string.
I'm casting it to a string.
That's essentially
just taking an integer
and making sure it's
a string, and then
when I add to this string,
it'll make it one big string.
But let's see what this does.
I'm going to try it out
with lower values first.
So the function is defined.
So let me write Fibonacci of 3.
So notice when I called,
it called Fibonacci of 3.
Then to do Fibonacci of 3,
it had to call Fibonacci of 2
and Fibonacci of 1.
And then to do Fibonacci of 2,
it had to call Fibonacci of 0
and Fibonacci of 1.
So it had to do all of
these calls to Fibonacci
just to calculate
the Fibonacci of 3,
and then eventually it
gave you the answer.
If you did Fibonacci of 10,
it's going to go really crazy.
So I'm not even
going to do that.
Let me just do Fibonacci
of 6, and you're
going to see how many calls
to Fibonacci it had to do.
So it had to do all of
these calls to Fibonacci.
So it was actually a very
computationally intensive thing
to do.
But the computers
are super fast,
so you don't even notice it.
But in the future we'll
talk a little bit more
of how do we think about
how computationally
intensive different ways of
implementing a function can be.